[Music]
foreign T based learning is a
pedagogical approach that involves
students in a long-term in-depth
investigation of a real-world challenge
so instead of memorizing established
knowledge or following an instruction
that offers a first path to facts
students actively work on a problem that
allows them to develop several skills
simultaneously
[Music]
to understand the difference we can look
at the experience pupils have in a
conventional class led by Mr listen and
compare that to what they take away from
doing a project with Mrs do the
objective learn how to engineer a tall
tower
[Music]
conventional class the students sit at
their desks and look at the Blackboard
Mr listen first goes over some
principles of physics and then instructs
the students that are still able to pay
attention to design the optimal
structure for a high tower
when doing project-based learning or pbl
the students sit in groups Mrs Dew then
gives each group 20 strands of uncooked
spaghetti Scotch tape a cotton thread
and some marshmallows then they are told
they have 18 minutes to build the
highest possible structure that could
hold up the spongy infection
[Music]
so what will the kids in the different
classes learn and what do their minds
remember
with Mr listen all kids might learn
something about Towers a few might learn
some engineering and one could in theory
learn to construct an ideal Tower
structure but just a week later most
will have forgotten everything
Mrs Dew's marshmallow Tower challenge
activated the kids brains in various
areas and taught the children something
about construction creativity physics
and teamwork
maybe more importantly they learned that
if they fail the first time they can try
again and still succeed they learn to
learn and even decades later some might
still remember that day
[Music]
the benefits of project-based learning
include High engagement and a greater
depth of understanding they practice
communication critical thinking and
creativity and as a result often
experience Better Learning outcomes in
general
randomized controlled trials involving
thousands of students demonstrated that
project-based learning significantly
outperformed traditional curricula
raising academic performance across
academic disciplines
the best teachers often combine projects
with traditional instruction or run
what's known as active learning
classrooms so that students get to make
sense of trying failing doing and the
theory from the educator
what are your thoughts about learning
through projects since education is
allegedly not about what the teacher
covers but what the students discover is
it the better way to learn
[Music]
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com